so i started saying last wednesday or
thursday when it became clear that joe
biden had an increasingly clear path to
270 electoral votes and
thus the presidency that he should
immediately launch a
parallel coronavirus task force parallel
of course to the official white house
task force
led by uh mike pence who has failed
miserably
who has replaced infectious disease
doctors with radiologists who spent
months downplaying the virus
and then spent months claiming that the
trump administration beat the virus as
cases got worse and worse and worse
well it's time for adults to have a go
at it and the co-chairs of
joe biden's coronavirus task force are
expected to be
vivek murthy surgeon general under obama
david kessler from the fda under george
h.w bush and clinton
rick bright may be involved who was of
course
famously pushed out during after raising
the red flag
during this current administration
everybody uh they have bo
or rather kessler and murthy have been
briefing biden for months
biden is considering many things
including speaking to governors about
mass
mandates which might be necessary the
way things are going
scaling up testing using the model of
president franklin delano roosevelt war
production board
according to advisers who are speaking
on the condition of anonymity
biden may start calling governors right
now
to talk about masks because it's so
urgent and i'm all for it
the point is biden's plan is for all of
americans
to hear the same stuff from the
president
from governors all levels of government
and how donald trump will react to that
we don't know
we did hear late last night that all of
a sudden mike pence will be convening a
meeting of the white house coronavirus
task force today
donald trump still doesn't even
acknowledge that joe biden won
donald trump may go absolutely insane
and go
get extremely triggered and lose his
mind
as joe biden starts to simply take a
leadership role on a lot of these issues
and honestly
my best bet my best scenario is
that biden trump rather just kind of
slinks off
and plays golf for the rest of his term
let joe biden get a head start and of
course once joe biden is in the white
house
he will likely go to congress and ask
for more money for testing more money
for getting schools and businesses
ready to be in a position to open safely
and interestingly
biden is even going to have sub groups
in his task force he will have a testing
subgroup
he will have a ppe subgroup a vaccine
subgroup and on and on he may even bring
in a coronavirus
czar who will be certainly far more
competent than mike pence
running this thing now i want to warn
all of you right now
republicans have been mostly silent on
debt and deficit for four years
because it's a political football and
when a republican is in the white house
republicans don't talk about debt and
deficit
remember trump ran on eliminating the
national debt
he's increased it dramatically now that
joe biden is coming in
just be ready for republicans to start
up again with
how how will we pay for it
can can we afford a testing program
can we afford a tracing program the
concerned trolling about the deficit
is going to be used to get in the way of
biden dealing with the virus
and i'll go even further after
downplaying cases and deaths
for eight months i wouldn't be shocked
to see those same republicans
say on february 1st maybe even january
25th
look at all these cases under joe biden
look at all these deaths
under joe biden we just have to be
prepared is the point
for stunning hypocrisy to continue and
even get much worse
good for joe biden for doing this right
away